let's start off with Nintendo our most
anticipated games of next year it's kind
of complicated because the Nintendo
switch were in that transition period
where there aren't a ton of confirmed
games a lot of it might be conjecture
which I'm not averse to getting into you
know acting like we know what's going to
happen when we have no clue at all of
course we have the entire slate of wii u
titles coming out next year I'd who can
forget I could again there there
literally none except or no there are
there's a Zelda breath of the wild is
gonna be on Wii U yeah that's all you
need that'll be on wii u first right but
it probably just dance so they haven't
said they've been really cagey about
like I felt like when they first
announced it they they had they'd
implied they would come out at the same
time so they said Zelda breath of the
wild is going to come out on wii u + NX
and i think everybody implied that that
meant they would come out at the same
time and they've been very clear after
that after the fact saying that's not
necessarily the case so i think they're
just covering their ass in case breath
of the wild is going to come out on wii
u and then later on the switch platform
although if it's not a launch game
that's just a huge mistake yeah yeah
gamecube thing where this is the zelda
game that bridges that gap was a
simultaneous on wii and gamecube it was
the same day no no it so it came out I
actually think it came out a little bit
earlier for Wii and then it came out
afterward for gamecube and then they
just mirrored them because i remember i
played it on gamecube first despite the
fact that came out afterward and i liked
on gamecube mortgage because I didn't
have the finicky motion controls there's
still novel experience at the time but
yeah breath of a while I was talking to
Pete and I was saying like if they do
really simultaneously obviously the
switch is what you want to go for but
who knows we're going to do that they
just released on Wii U right away then
that's what I'll play it on because that
game was fun as hell that's probably my
not just my most anticipated intento
game next year that's my most
anticipated game all three of us plated
at e3 I mean Rob are you like Leigh
historically a big zelda fan I mean I've
lost touch but I will say that I you
know like ocarina of time I've been like
four times like that is just an amazing
game and I think about like in my
experiences with the video games like
that is just such a game to adore and
yeah everything we've seen at e3 I'm
right there with you it is by and large
like my most anticipated game and you
know I'm going to buy that switch I mean
I don't have it I don't own up wii u so
that's where I fall in right like I'm
part of that market but it's still weird
right like you want if you're gonna I
know yeah if you're gonna release and
launch a console all right there but
like they do with the wii and gamecube
where they're like we'll put this out on
switch we know that's going to push
consoles and then we'll put it out on
wii u afterward for people that didn't
want to upgrade but right you have
probably the most well-known video game
franchise at your disposal you might as
well use it to pimp your console but
yeah that the preview at e3 that was one
of the ones where I mean even just from
that I think we all played like an hour
or something 45 minutes and then we all
came back to our e3 war room the news
like the press room and we were all just
like dude did you know you could do this
and then Dave Jewett from the UK was
like and I'd like seesaw like catapulted
myself up were like you could do that
what the [ __ ] and that like just from an
hour long demo we're doing I can't
imagine what conversations around this
game right are gonna be like when we
play the full 20 to 30 hours whatever it
ends up being that's my most anticipated
game period 2017 it feels like such a
modern Zelda like not just the tablet
whatever thing you have as a character
but it's things like the snowboarding
like just taking your shield and just
snowboarding down and carving up some
slope so I don't know like there's so
many elements of that game that they've
adopted that just make it so freaking
exciting I don't know it is weird
because you know they're borrowing kind
of from a link between worlds and the
idea that you can just tackle these
dungeons in whatever order you want at
least that's what they're saying and
it's like an actual open world but the
same time it it's the closest we've
gotten to the original Zelda you know
like just completely open ended Zelda
you'd have to find your way and figure
out what you're doing but obviously
technical limitations is not gonna be
nearly as big as breath of the wild but
breath awhile it seems like a modern
Legend of Zelda as like the original
Legend of Zelda which is super exciting
for people that like you know there were
people like to cry every single Zelda
after like the first game there are the
people that think like every game after
that well they're insane I know they
would have to be it's not you know it's
not like item gating like my favorite
seldom my favor
period is majora's mask and it that's
nothing like the furs Elda but breath of
the wild looks like it's taking like
modern sensibilities like to satisfy
modern palettes and combine it with like
like a lot of things like doom returned
to its roots this year right seems like
resident evil might be doing that we'll
be talking about that later in the show
just a ton of games like I don't know
Final Fantasy kind of branched off but a
lot of these iconic franchises seem to
be kind of getting back in touch with
what made them great to begin with which
is exciting well speaking about the
technical limitations of what breadth of
the wild will will well other Zelda
games would have been like like there
will have to be some scaling back for
this because this is a game that runs on
wii u just like the wii and gamecube
version we don't know a lot about what
the switches capabilities are but but i
guess some of the games that have been t
is i'm not even sure what we're getting
with them like so we are pretty sure
there's going to be a mario kart
experience of some time there's going to
be a splatoon experience of some type
and a funny Mario right and a 3d Mario
that looks completely new but with mario
kart in splatoon are these going to be
updates to an existing gamed if you have
them digitally are you going to be able
to tie into that somehow because it has
a or we've been told and we've seen it
that it doesn't have a disc system so
you're not going to be able to use your
wii u disk in this it has to have a
separate cartridge ok right yeah so what
would it be tis people thinking it's a
port of the wii u version to the switch
it doesn't look what else could it be
what we saw of splatoon in mario kart
didn't look substantially different yeah
it so so what is it gonna be you're
saying they like you could you know you
could buy your specific console
cartridge or disk what you're saying are
you advocating the like maybe it's
worthwhile to do like an eShop thing we
like would purchasing the game on like a
shop then allow you to play them both I
feel like they have to I viendo has
always been really behind on that but
they've also had great backwards
compatibility generally every console
has been backwards compatible with the
generation before that and this is the
first one this is the first major
console in a long time where that's
impossible unless they have some other
peripheral so if i already own splatoon
what's gonna make me want to buy this is
it gonna be a full price game like would
that be a new experience would this be a
twenty-dollar additional like just
competitive thing like i am really
curious how that's going to work like
splatoon is obviously going to be
another game there
going to be a splatoon to at some point
but I don't think that what we saw when
they teased it was splatoon to that felt
like the splatoon we already play just
with more competitive options to go into
another title Justin you mentioned a
rumor that there might be a third entry
in the pokemon sun moon group on the
switch so we know they there's that
there's going to be another Pokemon game
they've been clear about that and I
think the rumor the conjecture right now
is is just like the old pokemon games
would have a third iteration that came
out about a year afterward like diamond
and pearl would get platinum or red and
green got yellow that some people are
conjecturing that were from Sun and Moon
we're going to get stars or something
along those lines and that will be a wii
u exclusive version of sun and moon i
have no idea how that would work like is
that it is that just going to be an
upscale 3ds version because the 3ds
version of sun and moon is already
pushing the 3ds to the limits a lot of
ways you don't get a lot of games that
have slowed down on the 3ds but sun and
moon is actually pushing the 3ds a
little too far even on the new 3ds so I
think that's believable and then I mean
as far as third-party titles go you know
people are starting to announce kind of
confirm is what Skyrim officially
confirmed as of now or just so it's not
it's not official but it's really weird
if you have a launch trailer for a
console and you have that much time on
screen dedicated to a game like Skyrim
like I think maybe Bethesda to stop
ready to announce it they wanted to do
that on their own time it would be
really weird if that is not a confirmed
game but that's real I think that's
really positive in the the grander
scheme because it means Nintendo is
thinking about third parties again and
not just like making separate titles for
the switch but here you know tapping
into the zeitgeist of what are the big
games right now Skyrim is huge getting
that on to the switch like that would be
a really crazy amazing experience you'd
have a portable Skyrim yeah and then to
look a little farther ahead there's a
couple of smaller teams announced games
for the Nintendo search seasons of
heaven will be an exclusive but it's not
really seen 2017 despite that being our
conversation this is a 2018 switch
exclusive but it's about it's from a
French studio it's about
the young boy with Asperger's syndrome
and his french bulldog and ani both
characters are playable and according to
a google translate article from french
game blog game blog the title is
currently running and unreal urgent for
this is all from gamespot article by
jason names and then also there is the
sacred hero which will also be on pc but
we don't know what ton about it it's
from a developer simplistic but that is
also slightest relation 2018 so that's
two of the smaller titles I did want to
look at possible conjecture I think all
of us kind of hope metroids gonna come
back in a big way at some point whether
it be a you know first person like prime
or no we here person this generation we
haven't had a metroid game we had
nothing on the Wii U on the 3ds we had
prime Federation force Josh wasn't a fan
of I don't think I don't think many
people were you don't count that as a
metroid yeah like going back to that for
the first person roots like this is this
would hundra sent be the time to do that
and especially in the u.s. like Metroid
Prime was such a such a popular series
such a popular direction to take that
metroid formula it would be insane not
to go back to that yeah I mean it seems
even more so than that we you thats
which seems tailor-made for some sort of
you know classic Metroid game between
the handheld options available and the
actual just you know I don't think of be
that hard to I'd I'm kind of on you know
being reductive but I'm I just want a 2d
Metroid game or even a prime game i love
the prime trilogy even echoes which i
think a lot of people say is their least
favorite i just i want a metric game
really badly and if breath of the wild
animal a game i'm already sold the
switch like I really want one and if
they brought a Metroid out next year
that would there's be game-breaker it
weird if they didn't I'm sorry Oh is uh
is the switch gonna be touchscreen was
that confirmed or not I feel as a palace
yeah I feel like they haven't said
specifically one word here one way or
the other that's still rumor it's a
conjecture that there is some capacitive
surface on it which responds to touch
but Nintendo is not said like I don't
think we're gonna learn any more
concrete details about the system until
January so ya january is the next big
like news that's when the next news
rolls out for the switch what
the tentative release March tentative
releases sometime in March okay cool
alright we'll probably will definitely
learn that in January so january i think
13th they're gonna have a press
conference which you know you can watch
on gamespot com that'll be from tokyo
and then soon after that we're going to
have events all across the globe to our
australian office our UK office and here
in San Francisco we're all going to get
a chance to to try it out cool so yeah
those are the games we are looking
forward to for Nintendo in 2017 let us
know if we missed any in the comments
and tell us where you're excited for
you